si viste el vídeo anterior acerca de
cómo se suman las matrices espero que te
haya quedado muy claro y tengas una muy
buena idea de cómo se sumen las matrices
y ahorita lo que vamos a hacer es ver
cómo se multiplican dos matrices y bueno
hay que recordar que todas estas cosas
son cosas diseñadas por los nosotros los
humanos nosotros las definimos nosotros
las inventamos y bueno de hecho hay una
infinidad de formas de definir la
multiplicación entre dos matrices pero
la que te voy a enseñar ahorita que es
la que todo el mundo usa realmente la
que se usa en el mundo real
esa es súper útil y tiene un montón de
aplicaciones y te recomiendo que
aprendas ese tipo de multiplicación de
matrices porque pues eso es lo que te va
a ayudar en tu clase de álgebra y vamos
a ver un montón de vídeos con un montón
de cosas que necesitan que aprendas esta
forma de multiplicar matrices entonces
tomemos dos matrices y vamos a
multiplicar las
si es que déjame tomar unos cuantos
números al azar la verdad los estoy
inventando conforme los estoy poniendo
y bueno aquí generalmente surge una
tentación inmensa de agarrar y decir que
esta entrada de esta matriz que es la
multiplicación de estas dos matrices
seguramente te vas a sentir tentado a
decir que esta entrada es igual a 2 por
10 y que esta entrada es igual a menos 3
x menos 8 y esta entrada es 7 por 12 y
así y bueno no es una tentación tan
ilegítima o sea es justo el tipo de
cosas que hicimos cuando estábamos
sumando matrices y de hecho hay ciertas
ocasiones en las que uno multiplica
matrices de esta forma pero no es la
multiplicación usual lo que hay de hecho
esa multiplicación se llama la
multiplicación producto punto de dos
matrices y seguramente te vas a topar
con ella en algún punto pero esa no es
la multiplicación usual entre dos
matrices de la que vamos a hablar justo
en este momento que por un momento
olvídense del producto punto y de todas
las otras formas con las que se pueden
definir el producto entre dos matrices
vamos a concentrarnos en este producto
del producto usual entre dos metros
y bueno como hacemos eso pues vamos a
empezar por encontrar esta entrada y
esta entrada que es la entrada digamos
11 de que está en la primera fila y en
la primera columna pues lo que vamos a
hacer es que vamos a obtener la
información d
la primera fila de la primera matriz y
la primera columna de la segunda matriz
y con esto es lo que vamos a hacer es
tomar el producto punto entre este
vector y este vector ok y dicho con
palabras más normales pues lo que vamos
a hacer tal cual es tomar este 2 y
multiplicarlo por este 10 o sea tenemos
aquí 2 por 10 y ya eso le vamos a sumar
este menos 3 por este 12 y menos 3 por
12 y está toda esta cosa es nuestra
primera entrada de la primera fila y la
primera columna que entonces damos con
esta entrada a ver si nos cabe en este
espacio pero si no lo arreglamos el
chiste es que esta entrada está justo en
la primera fila pero ahora ya no está en
la primera columna sino que está en la
segunda columna ok y como para cada
entrada obtenemos la información de la
fila de la primera matriz y la
información de la columna de la segunda
matriz entonces esta entrada va a
utilizar esta fila y de esta columna ok
y entonces lo que vamos a tener es 2 x
menos 8
más menos 3 x menos 2
y ahora vamos con esta entrada que se
encuentra en la primera columna y por lo
tanto vamos a usar esta información este
vector columna así lo llaman y ahora se
encuentra en la segunda fila por lo
tanto ya no vamos a usar esta fila sino
que ahora vamos a usar esta fila esta
fila de acá que entonces va a ser la
multiplicación de esta cosa con esta
cosa y eso pues tal cual es 10 por 7 70
más 12 por 5 o sea 60
y finalmente pues vamos con esta entrada
que está en la segunda columna o sea que
vamos a usar esta columna de esta matriz
y está en la última fila por lo cual
vamos a usar esta fila de acá que
entonces esta entrada de aquí es la
multiplicación de menos 8 por 7 osea
5656 más menos 2 por 5 o sea menos 10 y
yo sé que todo esto se ve súper
complicado y confuso pero vamos a hacer
un montón de ejercicios y vas a ver como
después de tantos ejercicios te va a
parecer súper natural y lo vas a
entender perfecto entonces tenemos 3 por
12 36 pero que estamos restando aquí
tenemos 2 por 10 20 20 menos 36 es menos
16 no menos 16 y por acá tenemos menos 3
por menos 2 eso es más 6
quiero escribo porque más
2 x menos ocho es menos 16 - 16 6 es
menos 10 y por aquí tenemos 70 más 60
estos son 130 y de aquí tenemos 56 menos
10 o sea 46
qué crees me acabo de dar cuenta de algo
aquí me falta poner un signo o sea es 7
x menos 8 o sea que es menos 56 a todos
nos pasa a mí también me pasa hay que
tener mucho cuidado entonces aquí no es
46 sino que es menos 66 que entonces
vamos a escribirlo el limpio esto es
igual
aunque ya está acá vamos a multiplicar
dos matrices de la forma en la que te
enseñan en tus clases de álgebra pero
pues todavía tenemos que ver un montón
de ejemplos y después tú tienes que
hacer un montón de ejercicios así es que
vamos con otro ejemplo parecerá que se
me agotó la imaginación pero ni modo voy
a poner 1 2 3 4 5
entonces vamos a empezar por aquí
tenemos que estar en la primera fila y
en la primera columna también entonces
vamos a multiplicar esta fila por esta
columna y lo que nos quede eso va a ser
esta entrada de aquí aunque y entonces
vamos a multiplicar 1 por 5 y vamos a
sumarle 2 por 7 2 por 7 y eso es la
entrada 11 ok ahora vamos con esta
entrada que está en la primera fila y en
la segunda columna por lo cual vamos a
multiplicar esta fila con esta columna
ok y lo que nos queda es 1 por 6
16 nada
2 por 8 2 por 8 muy bien y ahora vamos
con esta entrada esta entrada está en la
segunda fila y la primera columna por lo
que vamos a multiplicar esta fila por
esta columna aunque y entonces tenemos 5
por 3 3 por 5 más 4 por 7 4 por 7 y
finalmente esta entrada está en la
segunda fila y en la segunda columna por
lo cual vamos a multiplicar esta fila
por esta columna así es que tenemos 3
por 6
+ 4 x 8
y si observamos esta matriz con lupa
pues fíjate que aquí están el 1 y el 2
de esta fila al igual que en el resto de
esta fila o sea aquí también está el 1 y
aquí también está el 2 aunque hay porque
estas entradas son las que están en esta
fila de esta matriz y de la misma forma
en la segunda fila también están los
números que estaban en la segunda fila
de la matriz de la izquierda que hay
aquí podemos encontrar el 3 y el 4 y
aquí también tenemos el 3 y el 4
y lo mismo pasa para las columnas ok si
estamos en la primera columna aquí vamos
a tener 5 6 7 5 y 7
5 y 7 al igual que si estamos en la
segunda columna pues vamos a tener al 6
y al 8 aunque aquí tenemos al 6 y al 8 y
finalmente al 6 y al 8 gay muy
importante la matriz de la izquierda es
la que se divide en filas y la matriz de
la derecha es la que se divide en
columnas bueno no es que realmente se
divide o simplemente usamos las columnas
de la matriz derecha y usamos las filas
de la matriz izquierda pero bueno hay
que sacar las cuentas y este de aquí es
1 por 5 5 más 2 por 714 5 + 14
eso es 19 y por aquí 1 por 66 más 2 por
8 16 16 6 eso es 22
por aquí tenemos 3 por 515 más 4 por 728
o sea 43 y 3 por 618 más 4 por 836 o sea
18 más 32 o sea 50
muy bien 50 y esta matriz pues vamos a
escribirla en limpio esta matriz es la
matriz 19 22 43 y 50
listo ya multiplicamos otras dos
matrices y bueno como hemos visto seguro
en algún vídeo nosotros sabemos que si
tenemos una matriz a y le estamos
sumando una matriz b sabemos que eso es
exactamente igual que tomar la matriz de
ya esa matriz sumarle la matriz a cierto
bueno yo te pregunto si también es
cierto que podemos tomar de hecho voy a
empezar con un signo de interrogación
que podemos tomar una matriz y
multiplicarla por b y la pregunta es si
eso es igual a tomar la matriz b y
multiplicar la del lado derecho por la
matriz a ok tú qué opinas esta igualdad
será cierta en ésta truculento verdad
bueno resulta que ni siquiera todas las
matrices se pueden multiplicar de los
dos lados ok
ósea y matrices tales que puedes
multiplicar a por d pero que ni siquiera
está definido qué significa eso debe por
a y bueno vamos a ver algunas de ellas
en el próximo vídeo
pero ahorita para que veas que esta
igualdad no es cierta pues vamos a hacer
la multiplicación de estas dos en el
orden inverso
aunque hoy vamos a hacerlo rápido
digamos que esta matriz de aquí se llama
la matriz a y esta matriz de acá se
llama la matriz b pues ahora vamos a
multiplicar ve por ahí vamos a ver que
nos va a quedar algo completamente
distinto a esta matriz que es la
multiplicación de estas dos matrices a
ver esta matriz de aquí es
por ver qué bueno también muchas veces
la dejamos así tal cual ave entonces
vamos a empezar con
que tenemos 5 6 7 8
que es la matriz b y ahora en queremos
poner aquí la matriz aunque es 1234
y las estamos multiplicando
entonces para encontrar este término el
que está en la primera fila de la
primera columna las filas las sacamos de
la primera matriz aquí recuerdan que
estamos usando las filas de la primera
matriz y las columnas las estamos
sacando de la segunda matriz ok entonces
lo que vamos a hacer como está en la
primera fila y primera columna es usar
esta fila y esta columna ok entonces
tenemos que 5 por 15 más
6 x 3 18 10 y 8 y ahora vamos con este
término que está en la primera fila
segunda columna que vamos a seguir
usando esta fila pero ahora la vamos a
multiplicar por la segunda columna de
esta matriz aunque entonces esta columna
por esta fila es 5 por 2
4 x 6 24 20 4 que y ahora vamos con este
término que está en la primera columna
segunda fila entonces segunda fila por
primera columna 7 por 17
8 x 324 y finalmente el último término
que está en la segunda fila y en la
segunda columna entonces es 7 por 2 14 +
8 por 4 32 y re escribiéndolo todo para
que se vea bonito
18 5 esos 23 10 + 24 es 34 7 24 eso es
31 y 14 32 eso es 46 46 cierto no me
equivoqué ninguna cuenta no yo creo que
no y esto de aquí es la matriz de por a
hai si son distintas no o sea son dos
matrices completamente distintas lo cual
prueba que ade no tiene por qué ser
igual a b a ok tampoco tienen por qué
ser a fuerzas distintas pero
definitivamente no siempre se cumple que
ave sea igual a bea de hecho son muy
pocas las veces que si se cumple
entonces bueno con estas dos matrices ya
vimos que es súper importante el orden
en el que se multiplican dos matrices
pero este no es el único detalle que
tenemos que ver en el próximo vídeo
vamos a ver qué
no todas las matrices se pueden
multiplicar osea por ejemplo cuando
estábamos sumando matrices vimos que dos
matrices se pueden sumar si tienen la
misma dimensión osea si las dos matrices
tienen la misma cantidad de filas y la
misma cantidad de columnas pero resulta
que eso no es suficiente para que dos
matrices se puedan multiplicar de hecho
ni siquiera es necesario pero en el
próximo vídeo vamos a ver cómo tienen
que ser las matrices para que se puedan
multiplicar